zu sagen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live auf ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und derzeit wird viel diskutiert über
die impfungen die korona impfungen in
ganz deutschland sie sind angelaufen
aber die kritik kommt aus allen ecken
und enden zu langsam zu hakelig zu wenig
impfstoff
das ist so die kritik und das wollen wir
heute besprechen mit einer der
verantwortlichen ministerinnen nämlich
mit carola reimann gesundheitsministerin
in niedersachsen schönen abend guten
abend erhofft wie groß ist das chaos in
ihrem bundesland
wir haben 50 ins zentrum die haben wir
heute mit impfstoff beliefert so dass
jetzt flächendeckend geimpft werden kann
und das sind ja jetzt im moment auch
alles momentaufnahmen denn allen muss
klar sein es geht auf einen impf
marathon mit einer langen strecke aber
das lief ja doch etwas hakelig an
niedersachsen oder ja wir haben das
problem dass wir zu wenig impfstoff
haben
der impfstoff ist der limitierende
faktor wir haben 50 zentren und wenn man
50 zentrum mit so einem karton 1970 drin
an impfdosen dann braucht man schon in
der große menge und die war erst zum
ende des jahres vorhanden und das ist
jetzt ausgeliefert heute haben wir über
200.000 leute gm stand 17 30 es werden
ein paar mehr
von daher das wird jetzt ausgerollt aber
immerhin acht millionen niedersachsen
haben sie in ihrem bundesland das wird
ein bisschen dauern wir wollen einmal
ganz kurz schauen wie der stand der
impfung überhaupt so ist meine kollegin
ina niebergall hat das mal
zusammengefasst
seit dem start vor gut einer woche
wurden in ganz deutschland knapp 266
1000 impfdosen verabreicht
doch die bundesländer impfen
unterschiedlich schnell ganz vorne
mecklenburg vorpommern mit 7,1 impfungen
pro 1000 einwohner bayern kommt auf 5,0
schlusslicht ist thüringen mit gerade
einmal 0,4 und nur knapp davor
niedersachsen mit 0,7 impfungen pro 1000
einwohner
ja frau reimann wie fühlt sich das an so
ganz am ende zu sein dieses rankings das
ist eine momentaufnahme wir werden jetzt
flächendeckend impfen und in den
nächsten tagen werden wir allen
impfstoff denen wir haben für die erste
um auch dann für impftermin
niedersachsen sie haben ja schon gesagt
es gab nicht genug impfstoffes wird auch
wieder zwischendurch wohl mangel geben
weil sie dann wieder doch kein impfstoff
bekommen so weit ich weiß es gab aber
auch noch den vorwurf dass der
bürokratische aufwand teilweise zu hoch
war da gab es stimmen zum beispiel aus
altenheim die gesagt haben wir müssen im
jahre seiten ausfüllen wir können die
bewohner teilweise nicht erreichen über
die feiertage andere pfleger sind im
urlaub war das teil vielleicht doch auch
ein bisschen zu viel bürokratie also aus
den pflegeheimen niedersachsen habe ich
das nicht gehört es braucht die
einwilligung natürlich in die info
eventuell auch von betreuern wenn die
person nicht mehr selber einwilligen
können aber das haben wir so nicht
gesehen sondern wir haben ganz im
gegenteil gesehen dass sehr schnell auch
in den pflegeheimen geimpft und wir
haben auch eine klare priorität auf die
alten und pflegeheime weil etwa die
hälfte der todesfälle sind eben in den
pflegeheimen und deshalb klare priorität
erst die wirklich hochbetagten in den
einrichtungen zu kämpfen da kann ich
ihnen einen beitrag empfehlen von den
kollegen von ndr 1 niedersachsen
die haben genau diese kritik gehabt
eines leiters eines pflegeheimes dass es
zu viel aufwand war und dass es zu lange
gedauert hat deswegen die impfungen zu
verabreichen geht das nicht auch ein
bisschen einfacher ja es braucht die
einwilligung wie bei allen die müssen
immer einen willigen eine medizinische
behandlung und das ist auch erforderlich
habe sehr dafür geworben dass das über
die weihnachtsfeiertage dann mit den
angehörigen auch gesprochen werden kann
und dass es in ganz vielen fällen auch
reibungslos passiert aber eines der
größten probleme die wir zurzeit haben
nicht nur niedersachsen sondern in ganz
deutschland ist die vergabe der termine
darf klagen viele über schlechte
organisation vollgestopfter hotlines vor
allem ist das in jedem bundesland anders
organisiert meine kollegin ina gerade
nochmal die das ganze für uns zusammen
fast wie bekomme ich einen termin zum
impfen jetzt da immer mehr impfzentren
öffnen wird die frage drängender vor
allem für diejenigen die zur ersten impf
gruppe gehören aber nicht in
pflegeheimen leben oder arbeiten und
dort geimpft werden
mitarbeitende in krankenhäusern etwa
oder über 80 jährige die zu hause leben
rund fünf millionen menschen in ganz
deutschland
doch die terminvergabe läuft in jedem
bundesland ein bisschen anders
in den meisten ländern telefonisch über
hotlines oder über online plattformen in
berlin bremen und mecklenburg vorpommern
kommt eine persönliche einladung per
post in manchen ländern kann man schon
termine vereinbaren
zum beispiel in thüringen
rheinland-pfalz oder dem saarland
zumindest theoretisch in nordrhein
westfalen heißt es der termin service
wird erst freigeschaltet wenn genug
impfstoff zur verfügung steht
niedersachsen hat seine hotline zwar
schon freigeschaltet
termine bekommt man darüber aber noch
nicht die online plattform soll es erst
mitte januar geben
wie bekomme ich also einen termin zum
impfen die antwort sie ist alles andere
als eindeutig also wirklich jedes
bundesland macht hat das so wie sie ist
oder wie es für richtig hält warum gibt
es da so unterschiedlicher prozedere
frau reimann warum haben sie sich
geeinigt dass zum beispiel zentral zu
steuern damit alle bundesbürger einfach
wissen ich wähle die nummer an oder ich
wähle diese hotline an
oder diese website jeder hat ja die
möglichkeit auch die 11 6 11 7 zu nehmen
wir haben uns dafür entschieden eine
eigene hotline anzubieten die auch
reibungslos läuft da gibt es
informationen bisher
und sobald auch impfstoff zur verfügung
steht das in den impfzentren nicht nur
mit den mobilen teams der impfzentren
verimpft werden wir auch über diese
plattform termine vergeben
die plattform ist da es gibt dann aber
das war jetzt handeln brauerei man also
jetzt noch einfacher gewesen zu sagen
wir nehmen bundesweit 11 6 11 7 und
nicht noch eine eigene hotline
wir machen eine bundesweite webseite wo
man sagt okay in welchem bundesland sind
sie dann brauchen sie noch ein neuer
natürlich ein ziemliches nadelöhr mit
der 11 6 und 11 7 da sieht man jetzt
auch leider und deswegen haben wir uns
dafür entschieden eine eigene hotline
entsprechend zu schalten und die ist
auch bekannt die wird auch gut
angenommen
und da gibt es jetzt informationen und
sobald wir auch impfstoff haben wir
machen keine luftbuchungen werden wir
wenn wir impfstoff haben werden wir die
impfzentren auch dann mit entsprechenden
termin versehen trotzdem ist es doch
relativ komplex ist es so komplex dass
wir auf der zdf heute eine übersicht
basteln mussten welchem bundesland jetzt
was gilt wo man sich hinwenden kann also
da bin ich dann zum beispiel auf gesetz
also aufgeschmissen wenn ich in hamburg
wohnen da läuft es ist so meine eltern
wurden niedersachsen dann kann ich nicht
mehr helfen weil ich muss dann auch mal
nachschauen wie das bei denen läuft das
ist ja doch ein bisschen verwirrend
alles ja die struktur ist aber immer die
gleiche mann geht anderen hotline dort
kriegt man die termine die termine
werden schriftlich zugestellt und für
niedersachsen kann ich sagen gibt so ein
qr-code das ist so ein digitaler
laufzettel dann im zentrum wo das alles
dokumentiert werden kann damit es auch
gut aufgenommen werden kann und dass
natürlich auch alles nachverfolgt werden
kann
denn auch dass es auch erforderlich bei
einem neuen impfstoffe werden jetzt
haben aber die klage ist doch häufig die
haben wir gehört dort lines sind
überlaufen man muss dutzende male manche
sagen uns sogar hunderte male anrufen
bis man durchkommt dann gibt es
natürlich die möglichkeit das online zu
machen und da gibt es dann die kritik ja
gerade die älteren die jetzt dran sind
mit dem impfen und das auch schnell ja
bekommen möchten die sind oft gar nicht
online oder sind da nicht so versiert
ist das wirklich eine gute idee dass
dann online zu machen
bei uns gibt es das online und natürlich
telefonisch aber der limitierende faktor
ist zurzeit wirklich der impfstoff und
deswegen das wird wichtig sein dass in
der in den nächsten wochen wirklich
kontinuierlich regelmäßig impfstoff
verlässlich an die impfzentren geliefert
werden kann an die länder geliefert
werden und dass wir mehr impfstoffe
haben also verschiedene ist ein guter
eine gute nachricht jetzt dass moderner
zugelassen ist und ich setze darauf dass
auch noch weitere impfstoffe die dann
eben bei zwei grad bei
kühlschranktemperatur gehandhabt werden
können
über die arztpraxen verimpft werden
können bundesgesetze müssen wir jetzt
sparen hat er jetzt schon darüber
nachgedacht was man machen kann und den
um stoffe besser zu verteilen die zweite
impfung quasi auseinander zu ziehen oder
den impfstoff verbissen zu strecken sind
das tatsächlich lösungen die sie für
tragbar halten ist es nicht auch ein
bisschen an armutszeugnis
ich bin da sehr skeptisch die studien
und die die erkenntnisse die wir haben
sind fußen immer auf zwei impfungen als
ein ist es nur belegt dass nach zwei
impfungen wirklich einen schützenden
antikörpertiter gibt und die zulassung
beruht auch auf zwei impfungen und
deshalb braucht man auch weiter zwei
impfungen und jetzt alles so verhoeven
ist plötzlich eine wette auf eine
verlässliche lieferketten und die
letzten tage haben gezeigt dass das eben
noch nicht so stabil ist wie wir das
brauchen sie haben jetzt mehrfach betont
dass es nicht genug impfstoff gibt für
ihr bundesland das ist ja doch wieder
eine sache die ist auf die eu-ebene
letztendlich entschieden worden das ist
im endeffekt doch nicht so viele
impfstoffe geben wird jetzt für
deutschland wen sehen sie da vor allem
in der verantwortung wer hat er quasi
nicht ganz so gearbeitet wie jetzt hätte
tun sollen
also wir haben eine knappheit weltweit
das ist jetzt das kostbarste gut und das
erste opfer arbeite die eu hätte mehr
kriegen können ja aber ich finde
grundsätzlich die strategie der eu auf
mehrere impfstoffkandidaten zu setzen im
oktober wusste keiner welcher impfstoff
zu welcher zeit zugelassen wird und auch
nicht in welcher produktionskapazität
dann die hersteller liefern können und
deshalb ist es schon sinnvoll das auf
mehreren standbeinen zu stellen und
nicht nur auf ein pferd zu setzen
trotzdem der impfstoff von biotech
kaiser der sich jetzt am ende
durchgesetzt hat da wurde erst sehr spät
ein vertrag mit der firma gemacht
nämlich am 11 november und dann gab es
auch befürchtungen das ganze könnte zu
teuer werden können sie das
nachvollziehen
bei pfizer hat sich noch nicht
durchgesetzt sind die ersten die die
zulassung jetzt erhalten haben es werden
weitere kommen heute ist bei der immer
moderner zugelassen worden es sind
weitere impfstoffe die vor der zulassung
sind da gibt solche rolle wie bei der
ema beantragt sind und deswegen glaube
ich dass man eine breite basis braucht
und dass das auch die verlässlichere und
sichere absicherung ist letzte frage an
sie braucht ein mann ihr
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil hat
doch mit relativ deutlichen worten
gesagt die kanzlerin müsse sich erst mal
äußern würde sich sehr zurückhaltend bei
gerade dieser frage warum nicht genug
impfstoff für da sind und wie jetzt
quasi weiter verfahren werden soll sehen
sie das auch so
es muss eine gemeinsame anstrengung
seien die produktionskapazitäten zu
steigern dass es nicht ganz leicht
impfstoffherstellung wirklich eine sehr
spezielle produktion hohe expertise
braucht aber es muss wirklich jetzt
müssen alle an den tisch um die da was
zu beitragen können und dass natürlich
auch die politische ebene und es braucht
weitere impfstoffe die zugelassen werden
das ist absolut wichtig aber die
kanzlerin sehen sie dann nicht in der
pflicht sich mal zu äußern
die ist ja im gespräch mit dem
ministerpräsidenten das wird morgen
wieder der fall sein
um die strategie dazu besprechen und das
eine ist den doktor zu verlängern das
andere ist aber eben auch die
impfstrategie dann entsprechend weiter
vorzubereiten
dann sind wir gespannt was dann morgen
bei rauskommen carola reimann
gesundheitsministerin von niedersachsen
vielen dank dass ihr heute abend zeit
wir uns sehr gerne so und dann können
wir noch mal ganz kurz gruppen wie das
tatsächlich abläuft in dieser im
strategie wir haben ich muss mal kurz
diesen link aufrufen
wo habe ich ihn auf der cd erfreut da
habe ich ja gerade schon gesagt
vielleicht können wir auf meinen rechner
schalten einen artikel für euch
vorbereitet der heißt wie man scrollen
so erhalten sie einen corona impftermin
ein sehr griffige titel und da haben wir
je nach bundesland aufgedröselt was man
machen muss wer sich melden darf wo man
sich hin melden sollte das ganze packen
wir euch gleich in die kommentare den
link dazu damit er das auch findet weil
das ist tatsächlich eine etwas gruselige
angelegenheit hier auch eine schöne
grafik wo wir sehen können wie der impf
stand gerade ist die viele impfungen hat
es schon gegeben impfungen je 100000
einwohner und da ist niedersachsen hat
relativ weit abgeschlagen
leider hatte frau reimann heute abend
nicht noch weiter zeit mit uns darüber
zu reden
deswegen ist der stream heute etwas
kürzer als sonst trotzdem vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit und fürs zu sehen
und bis zum nächsten mal